hello everyone and welcome back to the
TCC Superfinal season 17
it's starfish with white peace against
lil at chess zero and we're going to
show both of the games where the Queen
to d6 can Scandinavian was used as it's
very exciting
well it's exciting for me so I hope it
will be exciting for for you as well as
I almost exclusively use it against
efore in in bulletin blitz and even over
the board chess as I found it it just
brings black a lot of activity and the
there's simply a lot to do and I was
looking for something that offers a
black some counter play to e4 and I
didn't really feel like starting to do
much of the Sicilian or something like
that so I decided to adopt Queen to d6
Scandinavian as the most white players
don't really know how to deal with it so
here stockfish against Leela let's see
how Leela uses the Queen to d6
Scandinavian we have a four by stockfish
d5 the Scandinavian defenses on the
board captures Queen captures 93 and the
Queen to b6 this is the one we will
discuss and it does leave the Queen
maybe in the game a bit too early for
black to attack 4y to attack but it's
well that's easier said than done
as you'll see so the form by white we
have Knight to f6 and not Knight to f3
Black's most most common plan is to go
something like Bishop to g4 Knight to c6
you want to play a six and you want a
Castle queenside so this is what most of
the players playing with the black
pieces will do and it is what Lee let us
with a 6 g3 this is the most natural way
for white to develop you want to place
your Bishop to g2 Castle here and put
the bishop to f4 as the Queen is sort of
awkwardly placed on these six so Bishop
to g4 Lila continues in the same fashion
any human player would and now Bishop
the g2 is the most common move here but
here a stalkers goes for h3 first and
you'll see why
Bishop to h5 and now Bishop the g2 and
now like I said what you will most
likely see here is
Knight to c6 castles Queen side and
hopefully black wants to bust open the
position would be five but here at Lila
does something else instead of Knight to
c6 Lila goes for East six & e6 has never
been tried by a human player at least
not in any talk to your tournaments it's
not available in the database so it is
already as a move eight that we have a
completely new game so let's see let's
see what happens here
we have g4 pushes the bishop back rush
up to g6 and now Knight to e5 you no
longer have Bishop to f4 since you've
advanced the pawn to g4 so Knights the
e5 making Bishop therefore again a
possibility with Knight to c6 now Lua is
interested in castling queenside but now
comes the bishop that's a king bunch of
characters on c6 with check and here a
stock which decides to give up the light
square bishop which is obviously a very
strong piece on this diagonal but it
keeps the outpost for the knight on e5
which will prove to be an even greater
greater asset so b captures on c6 and
now h4 as the knight now also adds more
control of the g4 square the Queen and
Knight nicely defended and you're
threatening h5 to trap the light square
bishop so h5 by Lee WA and now only now
Bishop to f4 we have Queen to b4
unpinning as also sorts of nasty
discoveries are lurking in the position
Queen to b4 and only now Knight captures
on g6 threatening to pick up the rook as
well we have F captors and g6 and now
Queen to b3 kind of offering the b2
point but not really as the g6 pawn is
under attack so here a little a defense
it came to f7 there's no other way after
you to defend it so King to f7 and now
queenside castle by stockfish now and
not not afraid of the the semi open B
file we have looked a b8 threatening
Queen captures and b2 and now b3 just
defending and here each captures on g4
you don't want to allow white to do this
to open up the G file so HK % g4 Bishop
captures on c7
rook the b7 and now Bishop back to g3
and here rook the
h5 with the idea of shifting the rook
all the way to the Queen site to put
pressure on the a2 pond and also at some
point you want to play Knight to d5 to
overload White's night here and if I
played a well a game with black I use
the Queen to b6 Scandinavian and I had
this position will black I would be very
happy with myself so it's not not not a
bad deal even though Allah went into
that whole weird east sex line but okay
rook h t1 centralizing the rooks and now
rook the a5 a nice roughly balilla h5 to
a5 now going after the DA to pawn at
some point of course King Tubby one
anymore protection to the eighty-two
point and now Queen the a3 now the
thread is Knight to d5 to overload the
knight and capture on a2 so here Queen
to e to buy stock fish puts pressure on
the e6 pawn now of course if Knight to
d5 then you don't really have to work
hard the Queen to e6 is mate in one
since the the Bishop and pawn prevent
the game from escaping so what you would
have to do here it's not easy how to
continue the attack for Lila because
stock fish has pretty much everything
covered problem would a move like rook
to e7 is that stock fish has a bishop
the c7 now yes your pony's protected
here but your rook is under attack and
the only square available for the rook
is f5 well or h5 for that matter but f5
is better and once you do this then
Bishop to e5 now locks the rook out of
the attack on the Queen side and now
Knight to d5 will not be as potent for
example if Knight to d5 you're just
gonna character it capture it and now
Queen captures here there's no way for
black to continue the attack on the
Queen side so that's the problem with a
move like rook to e7 so here allele that
goes for a 5a for the moment blocking
the bishop and now again preparing the
Knight to d5 we've each captures D
captures on e5 and Knight to d5 allele
and it seems a little ass attack is a
success the knight is overloaded or is
it here doctors goes for rook captures
and d5
gives up the exchange to keep the knight
defending the a to pawn here we have C
captures and now e 6 with
we have King to g8 and now Queen
captures on g4 so stockfish is down the
exchange but it seems that this set up
with with only the night guarding the
King against the the Queen and two rooks
is perfectly fine and there's no Waverly
left to break through so we have Queen
the c5 now putting pressure on the
knight also pressure preparing now to
push the pawn with Queen to f3 stockfish
defense and now d4 attacking the knight
here and now the problem is if you move
the knight then Queen 2 a 3 will be
deadly as there is no more ways for you
to defend the a to pawn
so after d4 we have looked a 5 and this
is again a beautiful move by stockfish
not allowing Lila to give back the
exchange for example in Queen captures
on c3 you're just gonna trade and after
rook captures here you haven't really
achieved anything because it's 6 points
to Black's 4 and also black black Jeep
on is is really messed up so not not
much you can do here Brooke b6 you're
gonna go rook the e5 and white will just
have a much superior game most likely a
winning one
so instead after Luke to e5 we have
Queen to b4 Alleva of course that
doesn't want to trade Queens but now rug
captures on a5 Queen captures and now
again not not going for the rook here
really amazing stuff problem is if you
capture the rook then you have Queen
captures on c3 and it will be incredibly
difficult to get out of checks here for
example or whatever you play here at
Queen c7 you offer a queen trade Bishop
c5 can block this and now again you will
have Queen to e1 which will end in a
perpetual not much you can do here you
can go into the the defensive with
before so 21 check will be met with
Bishop to c1 and here white will keep
some advantage but other than that it's
it's unclear if white will be able to
win this so instead Stockbridge goes for
Queen to d5 now the problem is your
queen is under attack and you don't
really have a good way of declining a
Queen trade and on the other hand
there's also the problem of isse Evan
checks so if you try something else for
example if you try to in captain c3 e 7
check
opens up a discard
King here you bring a queen enter game
or night a night also works fine and
here it's just game over problem is
Queenie one check King here you no
longer have a perpetual because Quincy
three check King a three and thus Queen
guards the diagonal there is no way to
continue next is Queen g8 check followed
by a bishop therefore mate as the Queen
covers the dh5 square
so after Queen to d5 Lila has doesn't
really have any options you have to
trade Queens otherwise East 7 is coming
so captures captures but now it's stock
fish with two points with six points
against four so a two-point advantage
and well stock fish is very good in
positions like that
so Bishop to e7 and King B to improving
the position of the King King f8 with a
four and came to e8 with f3
and now a5 and here Bishop the c7 a very
nice way attacking the pawn forcing
forcing a trade of bishops here we have
Bishop back to d8 and now a nice trade
here you are up two points so of course
you want to trade as many pieces as
possible
King captures and now b4
just like that just showing us how it's
done creating the past a pond with a
capture some before a five now look to a
seven and even a sec saying that okay
the a sex pawn is off-limits if you
capture it is seven checking 897 check
pics of the rook so not much not much
going on there so King yet instead but
now King b3 now the King is marching up
the board and there is nothing for Leah
to do but watch King d8 we have e 7 with
check any trades are of course only
favorable for white so King d7 you
cannot even give back the exchange King
capture son before King e8 with King to
be 5 and now rook to d7 attacking the
knight King c6 look back to a7 and King
back to b6 now rook the a7 and a8 and
now King to b7 and out there is no more
square that is safe for the rook so here
Leah pushes g5 instead of just resigning
sometimes they do they do that we have
characters and the G characters on h4
King to b7 and instead of pushing Leela
could also start pushing but it doesn't
really work since white promotes with
check and this is now just made since
the night covers the f6 square so after
King b7 we have King the f7 a7 bye-bye
stop with h3 a 8 Queen and we run into
pretty much the same variation h2 and
stock which delivers mate with IE 8
queen and this it was in this position
that Ally watch s0 got checkmated sure
really really impressive stuff and I was
very happy to see that the Queen d6
Scandinavian was one of the openings
that they will play now I know what to
what I can expect from white but as I
don't play that each six line not not
really gonna be much helpful but we're
also gonna cover the game where Lila
played with the white pieces second
stuff is going for the Queen d6
Scandinavian so we're gonna see how
stockfish defends with it and how Lila
attacks it which will also be in my next
video just so you know yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank a Christian Ginette
mohanty Boca Putnam a Barry Mack Murdock
Phillip Taha and Dmitry often ganden for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
video see her think all for watching and
I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga the coverage
of the TCC super final checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world and that
Magnus Invitational is starting very
soon in four days so thank you all I
will season and have an excellent rest
of your day